et là j'ai dit s'il y a s'il y a rien
qui bouge pour la révision de mon procès
je viendrai dans un mois me coudre la
bouche
voilà bienvenue sur le plateau de tout
mon appareil merci vous êtes né le 2
août 1942 à Clermont-Ferrand père cadre
SNCF mère femme au foyer bonne famille
bourgeoise gaullistes exactement les
mutations de votre père vous amènent à
Nevers puis à Nîmes là il monte au
Grau-du-Roi une agence immobilière alors
le Roland agréé de l'époque vous le
décrivez comme un jeune frimeur un jeune
con un branleur tout azimut gâté par ses
parents
je vivais tranquillement c'est vrai que
j'avais aussi une conscience en
bourgeoisie je n'étais pas du tout
destiné à tout ce qui s'est passé par la
suite effectivement alors faut dire que
vous pensez plus Sophie qu'à bosser à
l'école c'est un peu normal parce que
les filles c'est plus sympa que que les
maths que les sciences et tout ça
surtout à mon époque alors vous entrez
dans la vie professionnelle comme
apprenti électricien mais à 18 ans vous
vous engagez dans l'armée pour échapper
aux joues familial malgré un frère mort
en Algérie
nous avions déjà perdu notre frère en
Algérie alors ils avaient un grand vide
et ils avaient un peu l'impression que
je spéculais sur leur peine et tout
c'est un peu les reproches qui ne me
faisaient je prenais ça très mal et donc
à 18 ans j'ai dit bon ben je m'engage
parce que tout simplement la société de
mon père qui était un ancien commandant
dans l'armée m'avait un peu baratiné en
me disant ce serait bien que tu
t'engages etc j'avais envie de partir je
suis par cette partie au bout de deux
ans et demi vous rompez votre contrat
avec l'armée et vous devenez
représentant en machine à coudre oui
alors vous gagnez bien votre vie à 22
ans vous vous marier mais comme vous
entendez pas très bien avec votre femme
le soir vous commencez à traîner dans
les bars à fréquenter les voyous mais
tout ça pour la frime quoi et c'est vrai
que j'étais tellement médiocre que ça me
valorisait de fréquenter des gens comme
ça
vous finissez par vous retrouver en tôle
pour une affaire de chèque volé prenez
huit mois bon pas très grave à la sortie
vous avez 28 ans et là vous trouvez du
boulot dans un garage chez un certain
André Borel comme agent commercial et là
vous roulez dans des super caisses vous
fournissez des pneus voler à vos potes
et vous inquiétez pas trop des
fréquentations un peu louches de votre
patron en fait mais c'est vrai bon je
m'en sers d'arguments d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui je ne n'y absolument rien de
ce que j'ai fait de bien ou de mal je
l'ai fait c'est fait bon c'est vrai que
j'étais attiré par cette frime je roule
en voiture américaine je gagnais
beaucoup d'argent à l'époque déjà
j'allais attendre Marie joue avec une
Impala Chevrolet pas un vieux tacot il
était toute neuve voyez à la sortie du
lycée ce que ça peut donner c'était
sympa voilà c'était c'était le agréé
pleine free
alors les choses vont se gâter quand
votre patron André Borel vous soupçonne
de vous intéresser d'un peu trop près à
sa copine Odile Boissonnet qui est une
riche et belle héritière qui a 28 ans à
l'époque elle vous plaît Odile
Boissonnet ne me plaisait pas du tout
c'était simplement la maîtresse de mon
employeur sauf qu'elle avait découvert
que André Borel lui avait détourné
beaucoup d'argent c'était un vrai
patates dans ce garage c'est vrai que je
voyais beaucoup de choses qui se
passaient sous le monde et déjà louche
déjà très très louche qui venait il y
avait des armes qui circulent il y avait
des des enjoliveurs de voitures qui
étaient qui étaient démontées remontés
et si vous voulez moi j'étais en
surplomb dans un bureau je voyais tout
ça alors je disais je gagne bien ma vie
tu n'as rien vu tu as rien entendu tu
t'en fous mais à un moment donné
effectivement il a un peu trop qui se
passe notamment lorsque j'apprends que
André Borel s'est fait tirer dessus à
Paris mais vous êtes quand même parti
avec alors je suis parti avec elle il
faut savoir dans quelles conditions on
parle toujours de riches héritière alors
je suis désolé quand je pars du garage
je dis je pars Borel n'était pas là
selon que ses habitudes et je dis à
Odile Boissonnet écoute je m'en vais
elle n'est pas à maîtresse
elle me demande je ne veux pas rester
avec Borel il faudrait que tu
m'accompagnes chez mon oncle à
Saint-Raphaël qui est avocat Maître
Disney avant qu'elle parte la riche
héritière a tellement de la thune que
avec son comptable elle va au monde qui
était au clou pour mettre ses derniers
bijoux qui lui restent de famille parce
que Borel la spolié complètement mais
elle part sans un rond je suis bien
placé pour le savoir et la plus rien les
vandaliser et je l'accompagne chez son
oncle Disney avocat à Saint-Raphaël
alors le problème c'est que le 10
novembre 1970 le long du criolon un
cours d'eau situé à une trentaine de
kilomètres de Nîmes on retrouve deux
cadavres celui d'André Borel donc votre
patron garagiste et celui de Jean Moreno
son employé alors vous êtes rapidement
arrêté accusé d'humeur du mari gênant
évidemment alors l'arme que la police
retrouve chez vous n'est pas celle du
crime mais vous êtes quand même
incarcéré à Nîmes mais je suis incarcéré
mais déjà
pour détention des tensions d'armes
c'est tout à fait clair et quant à
soi-disant l'histoire d'amour qui avait
été inventé par la police alors mille
fois vrai qu'après ne pouvant plus
ramener au deal dans son garage ni rien
on est parti au Grau-du-Roi chez des
amis elle est devenue ma maîtresse
forcément il est devenu ma maîtresse en
cours de route mais j'avais pas de plan
très précis amoureux avec elle il
fallait elle voulait retrouver son
garage moi je voulais retrouver ma vie
c'était comme ça et quand on le retrouve
mort bon effectivement avant j'avais dit
au commissaire de police qui venait me
boire fréquemment j'ai dit m'attendais
vous attendez quoi maintenant pour
l'arrêter parce que lui dans Nîmes il se
balade avec des hommes armés et moi
j'avais acheté un calibre évidemment
j'avais dit aux filles que j'avais dit
attends maintenant si on se rend compte
moi j'essaierai de pas faire le veau
comme l'on dit hein et j'avais ce
calibre là et je m'étais fait je m'étais
fait avoir parce que à la balistique il
tirait un coup sur 7 je l'avais payé la
peau des fesses voyez j'étais bien en
bas
alors l'affaire ce corps qu'en 5 mois
plus tard le truand Antoine Santelli
avoue avoir tué Borel avec un complice
nous méritaires Antoine Ritter à votre
demande
ces gens-là quand il me dénonce il faut
savoir qu'au départ c'est pas mon oncle
qui donne quand il se peut arrêter il
donne un autre nom et curieusement dans
le même matin alors qu'ils ont rencontré
le procureur de la République la nuit
parce qu'il d'abord des insomnies ce
bras procureur 3h du matin il va visiter
des jeunes de garde du garde à vue et
comme par hasard il rencontre Ritter et
Santelli et il bavarde longuement avec
eux alors qu'ils ont déjà déposés le
commanditaire ce n'est pas moi
et là le lendemain matin ils sont
réinterroger vers 7h parce qu'on les
laisse d'enlever au moins il faut bien
mon petit moment le lendemain matin
sûrement buvant le café au coin du
bureau du commissaire ils mettent le nom
d'agrès l'affaire des mains et voilà la
alors au procès le titre du midi c'est 3
hommes risque leur tête mais vous vous
êtes pas trop inquiet en fait parce que
Borel vous vous dites bon d'abord il
appartient au sac le service d'action
civique donc c'est-à-dire les barbouzes
gaullistes sont élites à changer souvent
de version et surtout vous avez
confiance dans la justice de votre pays
quand il y a l'audience du procès en
fait vous dites pas grand chose parce
que vous pensez sincèrement vous avez
blanchi en fait mes avocat à l'époque me
dit surtout tu ne dis rien parce qu'un
innocent ça n'encombre personne ça ne
dérange personne donc tu n'as rien à
dire il y a écrit à quitté en rouge bon
donc je dis rien malgré toutes les
absurdités que j'entends alors je ne
suis pas quelqu'un je ne suis pas un
saint et puis bon je suis très content
de palais de ça doit être terriblement
chiant d'être un sein mais
pas le garçon noir comme on a des cris
et alors l'absurdité de l'accusation est
tellement énorme je dis bah évidemment
ils ont raison ils peuvent pas me
condamner d'ailleurs mes parents m'ont
dit et j'y croyais mais tu n'as rien
fait on peut pas de condamner et alors
l'accusation posée sur l'histoire
de la relation amoureuse qui tenait pas
le coup de la richesse de l'île
Boissonnet moi j'en connaissais que des
chèques sont provisions qu'elle avait
pendant que j'étais en prison et ensuite
il parle de chèques en gros l'accusation
c'est que des gens que je ne connais pas
je les engage comme tu regardes et je
les paye avec un chèque attendez ça se
voit souvent ça non et un chèque qu'on
n'a jamais retrouvé promesse de chèque
alors attendez je sais pas je veux bien
être con mais à ce point-là quand même
non alors le verdict donc santé lit est
condamné à mort et gracier ritaire
réclusion à perpétuité et vous vous
prenez 15 ans oui et vous dites j'avais
l'impression d'être dans un monde à
l'envers parce que j'étais innocent en
fait
effectivement vous n'avez rien fait on
vous met dans une cellule vous tapez à
la porte vous dites attendez on s'est
trompé c'est une erreur et vous avez des
matins qui sont là qui rentrent dans la
cellule qui vous cogne et qui vous
disent mais tu nous emmerdes vous avez
l'impression de marcher la tête à
l'envers de faire des pieds au mur on va
vous obliger à bien évidemment vous ne
comprenez pas et là votre bonne culture
bourgeoise je peux vous dire que il y a
des remontées acides alors là vous dites
mais le président de la cour d'Asie les
assesseurs les jurés qui sont
respectables et respectés dans de bonnes
sociétés mais ce sont tenu criminels
puisque tu es un innocent vous pensez
qu'à un moment ils vont s'apercevoir que
vous êtes innocent vous savez au début
qu'est-ce qu'on fait on écrit à toutes
les autorités vous savez je vais vous
dire que vous envoyez une lettre de 10
pages ou un rouleau de papier hygiénique
c'était le même effet ils en ont rien
affiche alors c'est innocence j'ai la
hurler pendant des années mais personne
ne vous entend alors vous avez une
fourchette alors vous usez un petit peu
les pointes pour pas que ça vous blesse
trop et vous avez les le manche en
premier après l'avoir enduit de peur
si vous voulez c'est un acte parce que
vous n'avez pas encore pris vraiment
conscience
j'étais j'étais en pleine effervescence
mais je n'avais pas vraiment pris
conscience alors les gestes que je
faisais c'est correspondait un petit peu
à ceux d'un gamin qui ne peut pas
s'exprimer et qui veut qu'on attirer
l'attention sur qu'on attire l'attention
sur lui quoi et donc je faisais des
gestes comme ça alors vous avez laissé
cette fourchette mais on vous laisse
mariner avant de vous opérer évidemment
pour vous faire payer finalement ce
geste c'est ça qui est le plus terrible
en fait à peine remis comme vous dites
vous remettez le couvert oui deuxième
fourchette mais là j'arrive je crois
qu'à un moment donné je devais en avoir
au moins 7 ou 8 dans l'estomac parce que
comme il comme il l'enternait mais je
remettais l'album derrière en prison
vous mariez vous épousez Marie-Jo oui un
28 décembre le jour de la fête des
innocents et c'est pas une c'est
administrative c'est pas du tout
et puis un matin vous vous réveillez
après une tentative de suicide une
pendaison vous êtes avec votre mère avec
Marie-Jo à votre chevet et là vous
décidez de faire comme Pierre Goldman
c'est-à-dire vous décidez en fait
d'utiliser la pression des médias et des
comités de soutien il faut savoir qu'à
l'époque j'avais été psychète
psychiatrisé par un jeune médecin qui
était en blouse blanche donc je n'avais
aucune méfiance vis-à-vis de lui comme
je cassé un peu tôt de cellules il est
venu me voir tiens un petit cachet ça
fera du bien qui a pris les cachets je
les attendais le matin à midi et le soir
j'étais à mon insu j'étais complètement
psychiatrisé et là si vous voulez le
fait que j'en sois arrivé à me pendre là
ça m'a galvanisé complètement devoir
Marie-Jo pleurer ma mère pleurait alors
là j'ai dit il y a plus jamais rien qui
va se passer de la même façon et là ça a
été un éclair tournant et j'ai pris
conscience c'était mon grand tournant
oui alors pour intéresser les médias et
animer vos comités vous décidez de
prendre votre corps en otage vous dites
je n'ai pas prendre un matin en otage
parce que ça ça aurait été un [__]
si j'avais fait ça je me prends moi-même
en otage voilà j'avais un rôle de
victime à assumer c'est vachement
difficile et si j'avais trouvé des
moyens beaucoup moins douloureux à
l'époque croyez moi j'étais preneur
effectivement j'ai été obligé d'avoir ce
comportement mais également j'avais je
me dis le soutien de Marie-Jo qui elle
quand même a réussi à noter la France
alors début 76 fait une grève de la fin
un an et 28 jours super perdez 41 kg et
vos dents ah oui la journée elles sont
fausses
alors Marie-Jo aussi fait une grève de
la fin et elle se fait porter à
l'intérieur de la cathédrale de Rouen
sur une civière oui pour attirer
l'attention des gens
vous savez il a été très indisposé alors
on a alors ça fait un gros fourbi dans
l'église il a fallu arrêter la cérémonie
le l'évêque est venu partait de là etc
mise à part qu'elle avait l'adresse
perso de Jean ricanet donc elle est
partie volontiers de l'église mais quand
il est rentré chez lui elle était déjà
dans une filière devant il a été obligé
de la recevoir en 1981 place Vendôme
vous demandez à votre comité de soutien
de cracher dans un bol et vous vous
injectez les crachats ce qui provoque
une septicémie évidemment immédiate quoi
oui parce que si vous voulez le grand
drame il s'agits dès le départ c'est que
chaque fois je m'étais d'accord un peu
plus haut un peu plus haut un peu plus
haut effectivement quand on met l'accord
dans mes la corde on met d'accord on a
un moment donné
arrive dans les pires des extrêmes je me
suis comporté comme un barbare vis-à-vis
de moi je me suis comporté comme un
inhumain et alors croyez-moi c'est c'est
vachement dur il dit d'ailleurs je me
suis retrouvé dans une logique de guerre
mais je oui et puis même dans certaines
affaires je m'en sens souvent encore
logique de guerre effectivement alors en
1983 vous coupez deux doigts que vous
déposez dans un bocal qui sera mis sur
le bureau du directeur des affaires
criminelles et des grâces oui alors j'en
ai coupé un premier j'avais prévenu
d'ailleurs et deux mois après j'en ai
coupé un second et là j'ai dit s'il y a
s'il y a rien qui bouge pour la révision
de mon procès je viendrai dans un mois
me coudre la bouche il faut savoir qu'à
ce moment-là quand même il y a un
événement qui s'était produit c'est que
Ritter et sentellid qui m'avait accusé
donc à l'époque ils avaient quand même
produit pas moins de 19 versions
différentes bon ils ont été condamnés
pour subornation de témoin donc ça a été
un élément nouveau imparable pour la
révision du procès voilà donc
relativement fait nouveau révisions du
procès le 25 avril 1985 vous êtes
rejugés et acquitter mais il faudra
encore une grève de la fin et une balle
dans le pied pour être indemnisé alors
vous trompez la base dans de la bétadine
avant de vous la tirer dans le pied quoi
oui mais il y a un truc auquel je
n'avais pas pensé c'est que
à bout touchant
ça brûle vous savez le coup là là les
résidus de tir comme l'on appelle c'est
terrible alors là le coup par lui-même
on le sent pas trop honnêtement c'est
comme si on prend un grand coup si vous
voulez mais alors c'est d'une violence
ces résidus tir cette flamme à
l'intérieur qui brûle c'est la grandeur
et paradoxalement il a fallu chaque fois
que j'arrive dans 6 extrémités et chaque
fois la justice après m'a dit oh ben
vous savez vous avez raison elle m'a
donné raison chaque fois mais après
après
votre truc c'était de dire voilà je vais
faire tout ça parce que là à ce
moment-là ils vont penser soit je suis
fou soit je suis innocent il y avait
plus que ça parce que ceux qui pensait à
l'époque c'est un petit malin qui vous
laisse battre pour sortir de prison bon
attendez je suis sorti au bout de 7 ans
j'étais quasiment conditionnable on va
dire ça comme ça mais je continue à
faire tout ça donc il y a plus que deux
raisons maintenant ou alors je suis
frappadingue complet ou alors faut
penser que je suis peut-être innocent
voilà et vous étiez innocent là
évidemment les médias parlent de vous
parce que c'est rarissime que la justice
revienne sur ses décisions ça arrive
très rarement quels ont été les
réactions de notre entourage à ce
moment-là évidemment on a été très
heureux en plus j'ai mon père à l'agonie
je voulais qu'il voit ça c'était bon
mais pour nous
ça a été ça a été très dur parce que on
laissait un terrible échec pour nous on
laissait des années de vie des années de
vie torturé gaspiller derrière nous mais
vis-à-vis de tous ceux qui nous avaient
soutenus je peux pas tous des citer mais
des gens comme Claude Mauriac manqueront
enfin beaucoup de gens de droite comme
de gauche d'ailleurs j'étais vachement
heureux pour eux parce que d'abord bon
il m'avait fait confiance et puis ils
ont continué à me faire confiance et
jamais personne regretter et ça c'était
important et surtout je ne voulais
surtout pas que mes enfants mes
petits-enfants admiraient tout soit le
fils d'un Gratier parce que gracier ça
signifie qu'on a eu une faveur d'un
président qui s'adresse un coupable je
ne l'était pas je voulais pas être un
gracier tout simplement alors votre père
était à l'agonie au moment où vous avez
été acquitté votre mère
ma mère est partie un an après
parce qu'elles ont été vos relations
avec les médias vous avez du soutien ou
de l'acharnement au début je peux pas
dire j'ai eu vraiment un soutien bon
d'abord il me connaissait pas il
connaissait pas l'affaire parce que les
médias ils parlent de ce qu'ils voient
ils n'ont pas le dossier comme moi
j'avais pas le dossier d'ailleurs au
début
et ensuite j'ai eu très bon rapport avec
les médias je dois dire que c'est le
premier journaliste qui s'est intéressé
à l'affaire c'est un homme et Maurice
Rouquette qui était d'humidilibre il
assistait au procès n'était pas du tout
satisfait et lui il a voulu aussi et
Marie-Jo lui a procuré il a été Marie-Jo
qui Marie-Jo à partir de lui lui a
commencé à écrire des articles après
c'est parti qui a pris je suis monté sur
des tas de la prison j'ai jamais arrêté
de bouger en prison et j'alimentais les
médias Marie-Jo était le relais
indispensable parce que si je l'avais
pas eu je serais mort en prison je peux
vous le dire le pire moment de toute
cette histoire c'est quoi Roland lorsque
j'étais arrivé en QHS
et j'entamais ma grève de la faim et
surtout je faisais grève de l'inertie je
faisais tout alors grain de l'inertie ça
a été le plus terrible quand j'ai décidé
ça c'est que ça voulait dire que dès que
un surveillant ouvrit la porte je
m'asseyais je ne bougeais plus
et je leur avais dit si vous voulez me
bouger de la cellule faudra le faire sur
une civière et doucement parce que je
peux être très susceptible
et il venait alors Marie-Jo soligé à
venir de Nîmes à Marseille elle plantait
toute la journée par là il savait
qu'elle me verrait pas
parce que moi on me disait parloir il y
a ta femme il y a moi j'ai regardé je ne
bougeais pas c'est voilà c'est des
moments plus grands horreur parce que
j'avais tellement envie de l'avoir de la
rassurer de voilà et le meilleur moment
c'est le jour vous avez été à quitter
j'imagine chaque fois que j'ai invité la
presse c'était pour des trucs
dramatiques là j'ai un truc très sympa à
faire avec eux donc je les invités à la
roche de l'Olympiques
là j'avais réservé l'auber et tout le
monde est venu déjeuner alors j'ai brûlé
mon dossier avec du whisky et il dit
whisky puis alors
et puis j'ai pris voilà j'ai pris le
dossier puis il a brûlé il petit calibre
que avec lesquels je m'étais mis le pied
je l'avais évidemment des militarisé et
devant la presse je l'ai jeté dans le
Rhône voilà et c'était marrant parce
qu'il y avait des amis policiers qui
étaient là ils m'ont dit c'est la
première fois qu'on avait quelqu'un
sortira Cali et on lui saute pas de
cyprès
toute cette histoire si c'était à
refaire qu'est-ce que vous ne referiez
pas pareil j'essaierai d'être un peu
moins con quand j'ai quand j'étais jeune
voilà mais il y a vraiment que ça sinon
tout ce qui est passé on n'a pas
d'emprise dessus donc je vis beaucoup
beaucoup je vis beaucoup au présent le
jour vous allez mourir qu'est-ce que
vous voulez qu'on marque sur votre tombe
voilà et avec Marie-Jo on a décidé que
on se fera incinéré
et que ceux qui nous aimeriez éparpiller
nos cendres place Vendôme à devant le
ministère de la Justice exactement comme
ça c'est un lieu très propre très peu de
chiens viendront nous pisser dessus et
surtout on espère que nos amérins vont
hanter le ministère à perpétuité merci
Roland c'est très heureux de rallumer la
lumière sur vous et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de tube abonnez-vous et
mettez un pouce bleu